hey guys it's Tuesday I'm Dan and it's
time for some games what news
first up over watches new deathmatch
mode and map are now available
deathmatch has finally made its way to
overwatch with both free-for-all and
team deathmatch flavors deathmatch games
will take place on tweaked versions of
existing maps and the new chateau
Killian according to Blizzard the
dilapidated estate is set in
southeastern France and has recently
found a new owner in widow makeup their
way matches are kind of like a loose
housewarming party the new maps and
modes are available now for free on all
platforms Blizzard have also pushed some
balanced fixes to cactus as part of the
update Road hug can now heal while on
the move and will take 50% less damage
while doing so to quote help road hog be
much more aggressive Widowmaker can now
grapple more often and her venom mine
will allow her to see poisoned enemies
through walls my next-door neighbor John
crap now has two concussion mines to aid
in traversal and his ultimate rip tire
has received a speed increase to aid in
getting the explosive into position
before it's destroyed finally a recess
barrier has been redesigned to protect
against foes who are below her fusion
driver has also seen a speed increase
for those of you like me who had a hard
time hitting anything far away you can
check out the full list of changes in
our story on GameSpot or just jump into
the game for yourself I'll be there
tonight and I hope to see something a
couple of games demos for you to get
into this week if you like trying out
games for none our view dollars about
the neck too and just me too on PC are
available probably most similar games
out there yes basically the same the
demo for neck 2 is available on PSN
across Europe Australia and the US the
demo comes in at 2.6 gigabytes so you
can try your hand at it before it hits
shelves on September 5th
the original neck wasn't exactly a
classic and given our GameSpot reviewer
Tom McShea said there's not one element
of neck to excite you but hey let's see
if they get right the second time if
you've got no time for adorable
assembling and disassembling creatures
the destiny to beta has arrived for
those of you who prefer keyboard and
mouse the beta is now open to everybody
so you'll be able to crack into the
first story mission the inverted spire
strike mission and the countdown and
control competitive multiplayer modes
Bungie is also chucked in a new
multiplayer map for PC beta testers and
you'll have a bunch of graphical
settings to play with including 4k and
HDR destiny arrives for PC on October 24
finally the social networking feature on
the Wii U and 3ds miiverse is being shut
down binding
Tendo the service that allows you to see
incredible drawings amongst a sea of
memes will be shut down worldwide on
November 7 at 10 p.m. Pt don't fret if
you spent your time drawing a
masterpiece Nintendo will allow you to
download your posts through the miiverse
website the shutdown will affect several
games such as Super Smash Brothers which
featured a miiverse stage they're pulled
posts from the network to use as part of
the battleground Nintendo will also be
shutting down Wii U chat and the TV
streaming service TV their next two
major online service is set to launch in
2018 on switch and it's currently free
but come the full release will set you
back $4 per month or 30 bucks per year
that's everything we have for you today
do enjoy the rest of your day and be
sure to let us know what you thought of
today's stories down below in the
comments thanks for joining us once
again and we will see you tomorrow birth
destiny 2 on PC and nook to are
available for play in now that's perfect
with the spike don't jump like that that
close to this black